we all have our favorite characters but
today you'll get to see some of the ones
we love the most
we found the awesome fan art that
reimagined characters like Rick and
Morty Stewie Griffin windy from gravity
falls and more wait until you see the
human version of the Powerpuff Girls
give this video a thumbs up and hit that
subscribe button let's check out ten
cartoon characters reimagined by amazing
artists nany from lilo & stitch nany is
the big sister everyone once although
she's just a cartoon character
nonny's presence in lilo and stitch made
the cartoon a million times better we
loved her kind spirit and her maturity
she's incredibly motherly although of
course she can get easily irritated and
at times feisty as she has to take care
of her younger sister who's the complete
opposite Isabel Staub from Instagram
reimagined what she looked like in real
life doesn't she look like she could
easily fit in a Disney princess movie
come on Disney it's Nanni's turn to
shine
speaking of Disney Princesses stay tuned
to see one of our favorite princesses
reimagined by an awesome artist the loud
house it's no secret that we absolutely
love the loud house and so do millions
of fans who tuned in to watch the show
every single episode if you watched our
other videos you probably already saw a
lot of awesome fan art but this one is
one of our favorites it's the entire
gang sitting together in the living room
except they look way more realistic than
the actual characters this illustration
belongs to the talented deviantART user
called the acolyte artists who did a
fantastic job at portraying each
personality look how adorable lilius
even Lenny's into the video game they're
playing while Laurie of course is too
busy taking selfies Stewie Griffin
Stewie Griffin is one of the most
beloved cartoon characters ever of
course if we ignore the fact that he's
actually an amazing manipulator who
knows what he wants and gets it at all
cost he has an amazing sense of humor
and an even better overall look Stranger
9 to 0-5 from deviantART reimagined what
Stewie might look like in real life and
the results are out
lutely fantastic it seems like this
Stewie is far away from home and
injecting by his look he's been through
a lot of adventures their real-life
sewer definitely looks slightly braver
but we have to admit that this version
looks pretty scary Wendy from gravity
falls admit it a part of you wants to be
more like windy from gravity falls or at
least you want to hang out with her this
cool troublemaker is just awesome and
here chill teen personality reminds us
that we should be more relaxed this
version of windy was reimagined by the
talented Davina from deviantART who gave
our favorite character and even cooler
look she looks totally human and we
absolutely adore her long hair along
with her signature hats who wouldn't
want to hang out with a real-life Wendy
corduroy and go in adventures that would
probably land you in a whole lot of
trouble we're totally in Jigglypuff from
Pokemon out of all Pokemon characters we
have a soft spot for Jigglypuff this
pink round creature is stealing hearts
around the world and many forget that
underneath the sweet exterior Jigglypuff
actually has pretty impressive abilities
to charm you with cuteness and use it to
her advantage in a battle the very
talented Joshua Dunlop reimagined what
Jigglypuff might look like in real life
she's still totally adorable and looks
incredibly fluffy but don't forget her
secret abilities her powers grow as she
gets stronger and we've bet a body slam
from this real-life Jigglypuff would
actually really hurt Doraemon the
popularity of Doraemon never seems to go
away did you know that this adorable
cartoon has been around since 1979 well
in 2016 this futuristic cat went on
brand new adventures which made a lot of
fans very excited check out this awesome
fan art that features Doraemon and all
of his friends having the time of their
life the illustration belongs to the
talented deviantART users who goes by
the name of rice spirit the detail on
this one is incredible and they really
do look almost realistic although we're
not sure how we feel about a realistic
Fedora a month because to be honest it
would look kind of scary Dexter's
Laboratory speaking of favorite shows
how could we possibly forget about
Dexter's Laboratory
this oldie but Goldy might be something
younger children might not remember we
met all nine these kids have a soft spot
for this iconic Cartoon Network show the
talented deviantART artist by the name
of infusions did a fantastic job at
showing what Dexter and Dee Dee would
look like in real life
we loved the detail on this one and of
course the fact that Dexter stayed
super-short Dee Dee's tutu is absolutely
gorgeous and Dexter's Lab outfit is very
much on point this is by far one of our
favorite illustrations were showing you
today Merida from brave since we're
talking about so many favorites we can't
forget about one of the most unique
Disney Princesses ever
Meredith story is definitely special and
we love that she showed everyone that
life's not all about finding your prince
the talented Anusha Syed reimagined what
Merida would look like in the modern
world and if it's at all possible we
think we love her even more now her
gorgeous hair is still all over the
place but we're totally digging her
awesome outfit especially the boots we
feel like this Merida would still be
able to kick some serious butt in
archery Rick and Morty Rick and Morty
was definitely one of the most talked
about cartoons in 2017 especially since
they inspired McDonald's to bring back
the famous statue and sauce make sure to
watch our video on the fans that took it
way too far
cutie pie VIP from deviantART reimagined
a slightly different version of Rick and
Morty and we have to say they look
pretty cool check them out don't they
remind you of Marty and Doc from Back to
the Future
we love Rick's cheesy smile and we're
not exactly sure what Morty is doing to
his eye but these two are probably going
on another unforgettable adventure the
Powerpuff Girls sugar spice and
everything nice that's what made the
Powerpuff Girls who actually made a
comeback in 2017 these cartoon heroes
know how to kick serious but these
amazing illustrations were created by
the talented Isabelle Staub from
Instagram who turned every single
Powerpuff Girl into a real-life person
and she definitely did a good job
check out Blossom Bubbles and Buttercup
and they're awesome real-life versions
we love their hair and her favorite has
to be buttercup with her stunning green
eyes
same colored hair these have to be our
favorite illustrations ever
good job Isabelle what's your favorite
cartoon character make sure to let us
know in the comments and that's it for
our video for more videos like this one
check out kids cartoon characters seen
in real life see you next time
[Music]